and
senator from iowa one minute for morning
business
that objection in this town
political arguments often change play
places very quickly
actually observers could get a wic
whiplash when that happens
now just think about just a few months
back
before this election we had elected
democrats
scaring voters with irresponsible
conspiracy theories
that president trump was going to
somehow use his office
to interfere with state elections
or that he was in cahoots with the
postal
service not to deliver ballots
remember back after the 2016 election
the irresponsibly worded talking points
was that
russia hacked our elections
leading to polls two years later showing
that 67 percent of the
democrats believed falsely that
russia tampered with vote tallies in
order to get
donald trump elected
now let's turn to the 2020 election just
completed
those same people are now earnestly
warning
of the dangers of americans
questioning certified election results
think just for a minute those who
supported
hashtag resist
after trump's election are now
lecturing others about the need
for faith in elections
it's kind of disturbing to me the
hutzpah of some of the people around
here
versus what they're saying now i yield
the floor
mr president the senate majority leader
our nation stands at a crossroads in our
months-long battle
with the new coronavirus tracking
recent developments lately has felt like
watching a split-screen
television on the one hand operation
work
speed has fostered a modern medical
miracle
the genius of science has brought
forward safe and effective vaccines at a
pace
which just months ago many claimed
would be impossible for about nine
months now our nation has been treading
water all together
now the road to victory is in sight
but at the same time even as we see this
hopeful sunrise on the horizon
in the here and now we're still facing
an ongoing five-alarm national crisis
the virus is surging across our country
two days ago
my home state of kentucky set another
bleak new record that most kentuckians
lost in a single day of this pandemic
so far nationwide
since the start of december we've lost
around 3 000 of our fellow americans
to this disease every single day
meanwhile although the american people
had built our economic recovery with
more speed and resilience than anyone
had anticipated
we've known all along that recovering
prosperity would come hand in hand with
defeating the virus
thus millions of working families across
the nation are still
under terrible strain last week
economists thought we'd see a slight
downward tick
in new unemployment claims instead the
numbers shot
up logging 885 000 new claims
in just one week almost 900
000 newly laid off americans in one week
alone senators on both sides know what
we need to do
in the springtime when the country
needed a bridge we passed the largest
rescue package in american history
on a unanimous bipartisan basis now what
americans need is another bridge
fortunately this time we do not need a
bridge over an unknown
and frightening future but a bridge
through the next several months while
the life-saving vaccines can flow
throughout our country frontline
healthcare workers are receiving the
vaccine as we speak
yesterday vice president pence speaker
pelosi and i
all received first doses of vaccines
pursuant
to pre-existing plans for the continuity
of our government
these vaccines are safe they are
effective
they are our nation's path out of this
hellish chapter
so the first lines of the cavalry are
already arriving
we just need to help american families
hold on while the reinforcements
continue to pour in
more paycheck protection loans for the
hardest hit businesses more additional
federal unemployment aid more direct
assistance for families
a lot more funding for k-12 schools to
reopen safely and get our kids educate
education
back on track and perhaps most important
of all
a huge amount of funding for vaccine
distribution so that we aren't just
helping americans endure this battle
but we're helping them win the battle as
fast
as possible last night we extended
government funding for two
additional days the senate and house
need to finalize another rescue package
containing all the policies i just named
and many more we need to finalize
government funding legislation for next
year
and we need to pass these measures with
a big bipartisan vote
and get them signed into law without
further delay
we need cooperation and focus from all
sides
there is a kind of gravitational pull
here in congress
where unless we are careful any major
negotiation can easily slide into an
unending catalog
of disagreements let's guard against
that
the american people have already waited
for more assistance longer
than they could afford in my judgment
they waited
far too long for a relief package of the
same
general size and scope that senate
republicans have been proposing
literally since last summer
every one of us in the senate and the
house
represent american families who simply
cannot wait any longer for congress to
conclude
these discussions every day that we
delay
may very well cost more small businesses
their survival
costs more american workers their jobs
and yes
cost more americans their very lives
we've had productive discussions this
week
i appreciate the good faith spirit that
has characterized
my talks with democratic leader speaker
pelosi leader mccarthy
secretary mnuchin but the american
people cannot feed their
families or pay their bills with
congress good faith discussions
they need us to act we need to conclude
our talks
draft legislation and land this plane
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved morning businesses
closed
under the previous order the senate will
proceed to executive session to resume
consideration of the following
nomination
which the clerk shall report
nomination the judiciary thompson
michael dietz of new jersey to be a
judge of the united states court of
federal claims
and the clerk should call the rule